36 hours ago the biggest version of
grock 2 went online but as of recording
there is no paper no model card nothing
but a Twitter chatbot to test in other
words there's no paper to Gro or
understand grock 2 but we can still take
the release of grock 2 as an opportunity
to discuss whether large language models
are developing internal models of the
world Epoch AI just yesterday put out
this paper on how much scaling we might
realistically get by 2030 and what
exactly will happen to the internet
itself in the meantime the first grock 2
which was announced a week earlier in a
blog post where it said it outperformed
Claude 3.5 Sonic and GPT 4 Turbo but
wasn't released for testing the only
things you could play about with were
grock 2 mini a smaller language model
and flux the image generating model
which is completely separate from xai
xai are of course the creators of the
grock family of models now while I found
it somewhat newsworthy and intriguing
that you could generate mostly
unfiltered images using flux I was more
curious about the capabilities of grock
2 itself and if you're wondering about
those videos in the intro I actually
generated the images using ideogram 2
which was released yesterday I find that
it's slightly better at generating text
than the flux model host posted by grock
I then fed those images into Runway gen
3 Alpha along with a prompt of course
and generated a 10-second video it's a
really fun workflow and yes not quite
photorealistic yet but I'll get to that
again later in the video but back to the
capabilities of grock 2 and they've
shown its performance on some
traditional llm benchmarks here in this
table notice though that they cheekily
hid the performance of Claude 3.5 Sonic
on the right you have to scroll a little
bit I'm not trying to downplay Gro 2 its
performance is pretty impressive the
biggest version of grock 2 scored second
only to Claude 3.5 Sonic in the Google
proof science Q&A Benchmark and second
again to Claude 3.5 Sonic in the mlu Pro
think of that like the mlu 57 subject
Knowledge Test minus most of the noise
and mistakes and on one math benchmark
it actually scored the highest math
Vista now any of you who have been
watching the channel know that I'm
developing my own Benchmark called
Simple bench and two senior figures at
some of the companies on the right have
actually reached out to help me and I'm
very grateful for that but of course
properly testing grock 2 on simple bench
requires the API and I don't yet have
access to it now obviously I was too
impatient to wait for that so I did Test
grock 2 on a set of questions that I
used that is not found in the actual
Benchmark and honestly grock 2's
performance was pretty good mostly in
line with the benchmarks at some point
of course I will do a full introduction
video to simple bench but for now those
of you who don't know it tests basic
reasoning can you map out some basic
cause and effect in space and time if
it's not found in your training data
humans of course can scoring over 90% in
simple bench but llms generally struggle
Hard grock 2 though does pass my vibe
check and comes out with some pretty
well-reasoned answers in many cases it
does though still get wrong quite a few
questions that Claude 3.5 Sonic gets
right so I think it will fall behind
that particular model thanks to one
notorious Jailbreaker we now likely know
the system prompt for grock 2 that's the
message that's fed to the model before
it sees your message it's to take
inspiration from the guide from
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy and
apparently it has to be reminded that it
does not have access to internal x/
Twitter data and systems ultimately it
goal it seems seems is to be maximally
truthful what many of you will be
looking out for is breakthrough
performance not yet another model at GPT
4's level for that though we may have to
wait a few months to the next generation
of models at 10 times the scale of GPT 4
before we leave grock though it seems
worth noting the seemingly inoble Trend
toward ubiquitous fake images on the
internet and honestly I doubt that
that's mainly going to come from flux
housed within grock although Twitter is
where those images might spread I'm
actually looking at Google their new
pixel 9 phone can quote re imagine
images like this one now having a
cockroach you can imagine a restaurant
that someone doesn't like and suddenly
they can post an image to Trip Advisor
with that cockroach now you could
actually verify that that person with a
grudge actually went to that restaurant
so how would this be taken down and if
you don't think those images would make
people click or react well it's already
happening on YouTube and of course this
applies to videos just as much as it
does to images although we don't quite
yet have realtime photo realism now you
can let me know if you disagree but it
feels like we might only be months or at
most a year or two from realtime photo
realism so you literally wouldn't be
able to trust that the person that
you're speaking to on Zoom actually
looks like they appear to do now I get
that one answer is just use common sense
and don't trust anything you see online
this strikes me as some more isolating
that we each have to figure out what's
real in this world there's no sense of
shared reality or maybe we need
technology to solve some of the ills of
technology I was casually reading this
63 page paper from a few days ago and it
does strike me as a plausible route to
solving some of these challenges forget
World coin or fingerprints we might be
able to use what's called zero knowledge
proofs to provide personhood credentials
now if you don't know anything about
zero knowledge proofs I've linked a
brilliant wired video explaining it but
in short this paper did make me somewhat
more optimistic that there is at least
hope that the Internet won't completely
devolve into madness and then of course
there is the good kind of Madness The
Madness of creativity Unleashed by tools
like cling ideogram and flux here's 20
seconds of biller squinting Mad Max
Muppet Style
[Music]
now just five days ago the CEO of Google
deep mine Demis Aris said that they were
working on a way to trace the original
image or text from the training data
that led to a particular output and then
based on the fraction of the output that
came from that Source they could pay the
original creators but looking at an
output like Mad Max Muppets that just
strikes me as an almost impossible task
and if you thought it was only us that
could get creative listen to gp4 from
open aai mimic the voice of the user who
is speaking to it do this just for the
sake of doing it I think it's really
important that's such a pure and
admirable approach rather than by
recognition or Acclaim it's refreshing
to hear that kind of perspective
especially in such a Cutting Edge
field no and I'm not not driven by
impact either although if there is
impact that's great it's just like
imagine being on the edge of the Earth
you know just because you could be
that's what it feels like to me I just
want to be in the space where it's all
happening talk about a weird failure
mode and why on Earth does it scream no
before doing the imitation does this
justify the delay to the advanced voice
mode from open AI or would you not freak
out if it started to imitate your voice
most people watching won't really care
how the model speaks to them it's about
whether the model is as intelligent as
them or as it commonly known is the
model generally intelligent and on that
point you don't exactly get a clear
message from these Labs working on AGI
on the one hand last week Demis aabis
said that AGI is still underhyped I
think it's still underhyped or perhaps
underappreciated still even now what's
going to happen when we get to AGI and
post AGI I still don't feel like um
that's that's people have quite
understood how enormous that's going to
be and therefore the sort of
responsibility of that so it's sort of
both really I think it's it's a little
bit overhyped in the in the in the near
term and this is why I think we should
take much more note of actions and
results rather than predictions and
words when a model for example gets
better than human performance on my
uncontaminated simple bench I will take
that as much more of an indicator than a
press release or blog post if you want
to to learn more about the inner
workings of simple bench and how I might
soon be working with some senior figures
to make it go viral do sign up to AI
Insiders on my patreon I personally
message each and every new member and we
have live Regional networking on I think
now six continents I'm also always on
the lookout for people with Discord or
moderating experience because we have
hundreds of amazing members with
Incredible professional backgrounds I
personally can't always think of the
best ways to help people connect but one
thing that grock 2 gp4 and many other
models like it are definitely missing is
scale how much scaling we might
realistically get by 2030 and assuming
the companies are still willing to fund
it the tldr is about 10,000 times the
scale of GPT 4 there are numerous
bottlenecks to scaling mentioned in the
paper but the most constraining are data
scarcity chip production capacity and
actual power constraints even the most
constraining of those bottlenecks still
leaves room for models 10,000 times the
compute of GPT 4 and I know that seems
like an abstract number but you can
really feel each 10x increase in data
and parameters of a model for example
llama 270 billion parameters scores
around the level of gpc4 Mini on my
simple bench llama 3 405 billion
parameters not just had more parameters
but was trained on far more data scores
around the level of GPT 4 and Claw 3
Opus the obvious question of course is
what about a model model with a 100
times more parameters trained on a 100
times more data would it feel like a
breakthrough or just an incremental
Improvement for reference by the way GPT
4 is around 10,000 times the size of
gpt2 which can only just about output
coherent text for me though it's not
just about blindly training on more data
or naively expecting scale to solve
everything we can't all just draw
straight lines on a graph like Leopold
Ashen braner does we have to figure out
as this paper aspires to do what models
are developing coherent internal World
models if that's the case then scaled up
models won't just quote no more they
will have a much richer World model and
just feel more intelligent these MIT
researchers were trying to find out if
language models only rely on Surface
statistical correlations as some people
think to put it simply if they only look
at statistical correlations no amount of
scale is going to yield a step change in
performance but if they can infer hidden
functions that X will cause y they can
start to figure out the world more
concretely when given these inputs from
a puzzle they were also given the
programmatic instructions and the
resulting outputs they were then tested
with only inputs and outputs and asked
to predict what program had caused those
outputs the experimenters wanted to see
if the language model had built a Mini
World model and was following the moves
as they went along as you might expect
it's quite complicated to probe where
the language models are developing those
kind of causal models and so there was a
follow-up paper exploring just that that
paper's conclusion was that language
models are indeed learning latent or
hidden Concepts they referen other
papers showing that language models
perform entity State tracking over the
course of simple stories and also
reference the famous orell paper about a
board game that I talked about in my
cors era course obviously we're
simplifying here but what they found was
that after training on enough data with
enough scale in this case over a million
random puzzles they found that the model
spontaneously developed its own
conception of the underlying simulation
think of that like a very small
incipient World model at the start of
these experiments they go on the
language model generated random
instructions that didn't work think gpt2
by the time we completed training our
language model generated correct
instructions at the rate of
92.4% and sometimes if I'm being honest
I feel for language models trained on
trillions of tokens of internet data
they will probably have far richer
internal models if non-fiction wasn't so
mixed with fiction on the internet
sometimes I think we don't necessarily
need a new architecture but a data
labeling Revolution things like simple
bench make clear that if there is a
model in current llms it's pretty
fragile but that doesn't mean it has to
be that way ultimately we simply don't
know yet whether llms can even in theory
develop enough of a world model to
eventually count as an AGI or do they
need to will they simply serve as the
interface for an AG for example
translating our verbal and typed
requests into inputs for separate World
simulators or will their most common
function be for convincing deep fakes
let me know what you think and as always
have a wonderful day